[Applause]
this is my prediction for the
inauguration
absolutely nothing is going to happen
nothing
okay those [ __ ] not doing [ __ ]
you think they're hyping it up they
hyping it up they not doing [ __ ] they
got out their system
they said they found someone that like
they ain't doing this
[ __ ] nothing good there might be one or
two people but they'll get caught
nothing's gonna happen
no but no nobody's getting storms they
got the whole army in dc
they don't want the smoke they do not
want the smoke nah bro 25 000 national
guard
nothing happening that's crazy just the
amount of military that they have
it's sad that we need that and why they
got pictures of them sleeping why are
they sleeping so much yeah
all of them are sleeping all day you got
[ __ ] to do well you take a picture
standing up and then go to sleep
where's the pr from the army like that's
how you get invaded when it looks like
you're just sleeping
yeah that's why they broke into capital
in the first place the [ __ ] security
guards probably sleep uh-huh that's true
they post pictures of them sleeping bro
trojan horse bro
unbelievable did you see the footage
that the i think the new yorker put out
they had a journalist that went in
to all the into the chamber and like all
this [ __ ] while the
wildest huge like the storm in the
capital river like it was happening
and they filmed that [ __ ] the new york
post bro
that [ __ ] was so funny bro if you go in
with them you're part of it
that's what i said i'm a journalist
that's what i was saying
they stopped me but going it's just so
funny like he's filming all these people
they're like going through like
the binders on the desk and they're like
yeah i think this is like this is what
ted cruz wants us to do
they're like saying [ __ ] like that
they're like going through they're like
yeah like this is what trump wants like
they're like having like little like
chit chats with each other about binders
bro
the [ __ ] they know about the information
bro literally they open up one and
they're like look ted cruz is going to
sell us out the whole time and then they
go oh no he was opposed to the bill and
they go oh yeah he's still with us he's
still with us
these people are sad it's just random
news like talking it's still bad bro
that's why also what are they going to
do with inauguration what are they going
to prove
like what's the point of improving i
don't know like none of this [ __ ] makes
any sense to me i do these are losers
if you you never have a black vice
president because you you know i mean
like
if you shoot him you just have the black
president you shoot biden yeah
now you got your [ __ ] worst nightmare
as president the most liberal black
female oh you think howdy mine
absolutely i'm gonna pick who they hate
more than me because when obama first
got elected i thought he was getting
murked
immediately right i was scared when he
was giving a speech i was like all right
like he was up there for like 45 minutes
oh it was beautiful [ __ ] stuttering
and [ __ ] it's like hurry up
bro like why are you taking all these
big pauses
yeah yeah why
come on bro no that was that was
terrifying you just had a little
plexiglass stopping them
i do think that this plays well for for
biden though okay because i think that
it'll be a lot smaller
because like they have like the wall
built to like around the inaugural thing
but like they built the whole wall
around like the inauguration like where
they do it at the capitol
okay and like they're doing like it's a
smaller thing like the attendance is
super limited
why don't they just do it inside it's
cold
they always do it outside we got bands
we have bands yo they got music
people are performing yeah yeah j-lo is
pulling up performing what
lady gaga is pulling out demi lovato
right why do they singing why
why do we care uh it's just what
happened
to them
his history with trump it ain't history
with biden lifetime politician oh white
dude ain't no history yeah it should be
one handshake yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah cut out the [ __ ]
musical performance they gotta treat it
like a craigslist deal that's what you
gotta do that's
a lit parking lot go to starbucks shake
hands
this is the ps5 this is a 700 done see
you later we don't need demi lovato
singing a [ __ ] song about how she
used to be skinny
okay no this is why are we having this
this is so stupid
j-lo is gonna dance yeah i don't know my
name well i don't know if they
wasn't she's 50 years old
they do super bowl 2.0 if they run that
[ __ ] back wait what if they do the super
bowl
super
pandemic pandemic we could have a
[ __ ] what is it called oscars no what
is
this
[ __ ] grammys grammys we're gonna do
the grammys for the inauguration
i'm watching joe biden sniff j lo's wig
you know what i mean
but in all seriousness like what are we
doing out here you can't celebrate when
they're [ __ ] to do
right as far as i'm concerned about i
see a politician
celebrating anything you need to get
shot
come on son sorry is your birthday you
need to go to the side of the vaccine
yeah because you're getting older every
year on your birthday it's your birthday
don't celebrate your birthday get the
vaccine no you don't need to get shot
but you need to be
put in prison or something
why are you celebrating do something
isn't it their job to do [ __ ]
you got a job to do bro ain't no
celebrating you just got here
unbelievable i'm celebrating you got
here no you've been here it wasn't even
that big of a move
we gotta watch biden stumble through all
the [ __ ] vows and [ __ ]
nah they gotta have him doped up bro he
could kill that [ __ ] you think so yeah
like he
[ __ ] ran out last time when he got
when he won the election yeah
guys gonna hobble out to the damn podium
i think i think when he talks he's just
squinting all the time like you can't
see that you got a cataract you know
yeah yeah it is a little bothersome guys
you think
was gonna hit that right hold on one
conversation at a time
what is
if i know indian women probably
be a pain in the ass
how long have we got to be here for this
what's going on
why is it all about you it's like the
color in his house
why it's so boring the floors
no in all seriousness this this whole
thing is absolutely ridiculous
let's go power switched over done done
and not especially because
trump's not even going to be there
that's possible he can't even do half
the inauguration [ __ ]
wait why was trump supposed to hand them
i think they they do a handshake the
first lady
they tap it up they tap it up real quick
they do the peaceful transition they go
yo
yo that guy's a [ __ ] bro he's a [ __ ]
what do you think he's doing on
inauguration if you're trump what do you
do on inauguration day
he can't even tweet dog he's gonna be
going crazy because
normally he just tweets when he's upset
gets it all out
now he can't do nothing he's gonna be on
parliament nobody watching
just smacking baron around way up here
get eight feet long
to make a statement like to during the
inauguration like if i was
uh trump i would make all the attention
on me like i have something to say oh
steal the attention yeah but how we mean
oh i'll do his own inauguration
i'm talking about a coup i think i'm
talking about yeah i think you're saying
so he's gonna re-inaugurate himself yo
that's actually not a bad one
that's actually not i'm here for four
more years that's what you should do
yeah
fire but who's going to air it cnn
probably [ __ ]
definitely because haven't they like
lacked news
stuff since trump and yeah yeah that's
what they will never acknowledge
they got this guy elected just as much
as anybody else oh my god because they
needed
me crazy they need them they love when
he goes crazy it just me absolutely
crazy that they could like take a moral
um they could take like the what's it
called the moral high diagram
they could like high ground like after
the presidency is over like
twitter banning him and all these other
like alt-right supremacist
groups it's like you built them you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] jack dorsey you built these up
you profited off of it you let him tweet
on it every single day
and now when it's a problem you go oh we
need to fix this you knew was going to
be a problem
you saw people tweeting about it you
know every single tweet when somebody
tweets something a little too [ __ ] up
don't they block it
they block my stand-up videos when i
make a joke if i was some alright dude
on twitter i'd be so insecure if i
didn't get blocked
yeah you weren't trying harder there's
gotta be one that's like what the [ __ ]
i was doing every day [ __ ] clan hoods
that's how i would feel if i heard they
would brag about that [ __ ]
they would be like yo uh i had 20 pages
blocked and [ __ ] like that
that's a teardrop one little twitter
bird
[Applause]